[Música]
el salvador se convirtió hace un mes el
pasado 7 de septiembre en el primer país
del mundo en hacer del bitcoin una
moneda de curso legal junto al dólar que
sustituyó a la moneda nacional hace ya
20 años el presidente en allí buque le
había anunciado esa innovación como una
forma de impulsar el desarrollo
económico haciendo que ese país sea
menos dependiente del dólar
estadounidense pero un mes después la
moneda digital sigue generando rechazo
para una gran mayoría de esta población
para ello le doy la bienvenida a nuestra
segunda invitada del día ella es ana
ojeda abogada especialista en blog jane
y también cripto activos y sido de liga
proxy layers gracias ana por estar aquí
con nosotros en directo américa muy buen
día por supuesto inició por preguntarle
cómo avanza el bitcoin en el salvador a
un mes de la entrada en vigor como una
moneda legal vigente cuál es el balance
hola buenos días bueno siempre un gusto
estar con ustedes acá enfrente
conversando sobre estos temas tan
polémicos e innovadores hoy vamos a
hablar sobre el avance de la ley disco
en el salvador y cómo está siendo
tomada por la ciudadanía tú decías que
hay un gran rechazo de la población yo
creo que ese rechazo pudiéramos decir en
pronto que es difícil porque si bien hay
personas dentro de los partidos
políticos y dentro de la población que
se han puesto seriamente a la
implementación de la ley vi con el
salvador también tenemos una parte de la
población que no podemos ignorar y que
se está viendo beneficiada por la
implementación del bitcoin como moneda
de curso legal en el salvador
entendimiento ahora mismo en este mes de
implementación y apenas entró en
vigencia el 7 se entiende la ley el 10
entró en vigencia la ley vimos como el
precio del disco en cambio abruptamente
lo cual tuvo muchas personas diciendo
bueno por extra que lo queríamos elvis
por porque fue una moneda que es volátil
porque es más activo y que sube y baja y
que va a asentar la economía de salvador
en ser pero lo cierto es que es también
estamos viendo beneficios como por
ejemplo desde hace dos días cuando el
abismo ha comenzado a subir y los
ciudadanos el salvador está y recibiendo
los beneficios propios de esa subida de
ese aumento de precios además de otras
medidas que han sido anunciadas por
daños bucales como por ejemplo un
pequeño subsidio en el pago de la
gasolina si se utiliza la billetera
jimmy walles que es la que ha sido
diseñada por su gobierno pero también el
tema de las remesas que yo creo que es
muy importante que universal porque
sabemos que el salvador es un país
dependiente en una quinta parte de su
economía de el envío y la recepción de
remesas así es a nadie quiere preguntar
entonces si este rechazo por parte de la
población no tiene que ver con la falta
de información y que es algo nuevo que
pues los nuevos cambios como ya sabemos
en todos los sentidos generan generar un
poco de rechazo y también le pregunta si
se puede confiar en el bitcoin con la
fluctuación que tiene esta cripto moneda
más es característica y también lo
dijiste en esta introducción de nuestro
tema
si mira yo creo que el rechazo en el
salvador podemos analizarlo ver los dos
vertientes la primera tenemos la ley
bitcoin que fue presentada el congreso
que fue discutida en forma casi veloz
que fue aprobada según lo que tiene un
grupo de la oposición que tiene que
ocupar en el salvador sin la consulta de
la ciudadanía sin la consulta a los
gremios y esto genera claramente de
falta un primer rechazo porque es como
casi imponer un nuevo esquema económico
que no solamente va a incidir en la vida
de los salvadoreños sino en los
comerciantes sino en el régimen
macroeconómico de ese país las
relaciones con sus proveedores
internacionales con los envíos
internacionales con los demás países así
que no es un cambio es tan sencillo de
implementar creo que ha sido la primera
fuente de rechazo tal vez la falta de
consulta o la falta de discusión de la
ciudadanía con los premios por otra
parte creo que también el resto proviene
de la falta de educación de la falta de
información tenemos que vivir con
relación a tecnologías que es
relativamente nueva la tecnología
blogging hay muchos ciudadanos que no
saben cómo esto funciona en muchos
ciudadanos que asocian bitcoin con dos
factores primero con kevin que
supuestamente han utilizado para lavar
capitales o para el terrorismo y también
no son sean primariamente en la
volatibilidad en el vector que es un
riesgo está allí que no podemos negarlo
y que es causar ruido causa preocupación
por parte de los ciudadanos que piensan
que van a perder su dinero en el caso de
los comerciantes específicamente ha
dicho una parte importante del premio
comerciantes que tienen miedo que no
quieren aceptar bien porque no quieren
perder sus ganancias y a esto le ha
salido todo en forma muy inteligente al
paso en equipo que él y sus asesores
cuando han dicho una y otra vez que los
comerciantes si bien por las
exposiciones del artículo 7 de la ley
virtual están obligados a aceptarlos
como forma de pago porque es moneda de
curso legal porque el gobierno del mismo
que le las garantiza según lo que han
dicho esa convertibilidad inmediata de
bitcoin a dólar para que no se vean
afectados por la fluctuación de negativo
ahora eso eso eso lo quería comentar qué
tan riesgoso es para los usuarios este
bitcoin que lo respalda cuál es cuál es
su garantía digamos si el bitcoin mañana
se desploma el gobierno en allí bukele
tiene la capacidad de responderle este
dinero perdido a la gente que está
usando ahora el saldo ahora el bitcoin
mira yo creo que ese es uno de los
puntos más interesantes porque tenemos
por ejemplo a dos actores que yo creo
que son claves con este tema la
implementación de la ley before y es
abajo que tú me mencionas sobre cine qué
papel está en capacidad o no en
responder a la población de responder a
los comerciantes fíjate el fondo
monetario internacional nada más y nada
menos aquí en lalín que han estado
solicitando un préstamo o un crédito y
el banco internacional de pagos han
dicho que no van a asistir a la búsqueda
el gobierno del salvador en la
implementación de la ley become porque
creen que es un activo altamente volátil
y que es claramente riesgoso para la
economía del país específicamente cuando
hablamos de las reservas o de sébaco he
mencionado al principio que respalda bid
con sencillamente habéis cuando la
espalda lo mismo que la espalda al dólar
la confianza la demanda y la oferta en
el mercado así que yo creo que uno de
los factores interesantes a analizar y
que veremos en el transcurso del tiempo
como lo empezar a manejar el gobierno
del salvado es precisamente ese bascopé
es cómo responder cuando el precio del
vídeo entraigas o disminuya es una
realidad
un día que la ley vi cuando entre en
vigencia cuando el precio se desplomó
casi dos mil dólares y muchas personas
empezaron con desastres
con el tema de conectividad en el
salvador que sabemos que es un país que
pues más del 50 por ciento de las
personas no tiene acceso a las
tecnologías a la conectividad y hay
también pues en pequeñas empresas a
tenderos tienditas de barrio también en
cómo se llaman que no tienen acceso a
este internet cómo hacer para que está
archivo cuál es para que el bitcoin sea
utilizado ya masivamente en el país
sabemos que evidentemente apenas tiene
un mes de curso esta moneda pero como
está haciendo entonces el gobierno
salvadoreño para poder ampliar masificar
el bitcoin
mira los anuncios que ha hecho en estos
últimos dos meses nadie busque el
específicamente cuando presenta la ley
bitcoin el anuncio en alianza con una
empresa que se llama blogs string que es
la empresa que básicamente éste consume
o diseñas redes satelitales
obviamente basadas en tecnología loncin
ha anunciado esta alianza para proveer a
estas zonas precisamente rurales que no
tienen acceso a internet para que puedan
tener mejor conectividad y puedan
acceder no solamente los seres en el
archivo valor sino además a cualquier
proveedor que les permita utilizar el
micro y recibir cualquier cristo poleas
y niell ese es el plan si bien es lo que
está diseñado si bien eso es lo que el
gobierno anunciado lo que vemos en
implementación todavía hay una gran
parte de la población salvadoreña que no
puede acceder todavía al uso en
billeteras o el chains escrito en
monedas porque pues no tiene la
publicidad suficiente sin embargo yo
creo que se le dan voto a la mujer que
tal como tú decías apenas en un mes ya
entra en vigencia la ley es muy porque
es muy pronto y seguramente veremos un
esfuerzo por parte del gobierno aunque
electo de diseñar y desarrollar
efectivamente esta infraestructura para
un país claramente no tiene la mejor con
estudiantes